Cam Newton's signing with the England
Patriots New England Patriots this is
huge Jesus really big and what's
interesting is now I'm sure people
rooted for him but he's kind of a get
you know he made a ton of money whose
MVP in 2014 I think John 15 so he's a
stud but he's taking more hits than any
other quarterback than a fan oh yeah so
he said like these injuries I didn't
know that yeah but he's signed with New
England and it's basically it's a
one-year deal all off incentives so if
he plays well he'll get paid I feel like
people are in a really root form now
right smart move right yes it does he 31
psych based I mean that's your glory
that's your glory context we play
another seven eight years no not with
his playing stuff but but yeah why cuz
you just get read Thanks he's had so
much injury really good three years for
sure
Wow and I guess Richard Sherman's not
happy with how much he's making the
one-year deal pay the veteran correct
more than 1 million he could run up to 7
million incentives but he well here's
thing no one had wanted to you know take
a risk on him cuz he has he had like he
had foot surgery on a knee surgery and
he's been beat up so the Patriots doing
what the Patriots do they signing like
they've done it more Thran Dimas Corey
Dillon I you know I would imagine
bouncing will protect him with his line
with his offensive scheme right I mean
they try yeah and then Sherman posted
how many former League MVPs have signed
for the league minimum asked for a
friend just ridiculous Tristan at talent
in less-dense cubies again 50 so why did
he why did he say yes to it cuz he wants
to play for him no that's a bad well no
that's about it no one's picking him up
at all what the [ __ ] I'm amazed what
because of his injuries because they
feel like he's I don't know for whatever
was maybe they're like his attitude
injuries am Sherman's right but also it
shows you how bad can didn't want to
play cuz I bet you Colin Kaepernick went
sign for him for that deal that's
amazing I would have thought he'd sign
for a hundred and fifty million dollars
or something Jesus no Jesus
oh here I'd imagine he's got a lot of
money in the bank as it is you would
hope yeah tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]